foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
whatever
[Music]
[Music]
whatever
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh you found the original asset
yeah I found the original asset we lied
by the way
we live what's going on guys King's
still watching the original asset
he's memorized by it you know taking a
couple seconds to catch up to to roll
like I'm not memorized by a mesmerized
by It Whatever whatever so we we do got
to guess the first guest of our uh my
friend Tyler he's gonna he's gonna kick
it with us today uh you guys doing and
then and then we got we got King
obviously uh we we all have watched
Avatar may I add uh me and the girl
watched it like Friday or something like
that he said the girl and uh this was
purple yeah and and King watched it
Friday and Tyler I think watched it
Sunday so we all have seen it we'll give
our opinions on it there is a little bit
more to talk about uh there we have
go we have do new stuff that we're going
to do with um
the overlays
and that will probably be I would say
next week I looked in there today it
wasn't in there King
so okay no problem
so what's going on you guys R and R uh r
r with King and an addict we have some
DC news to talk about today uh they're
gonna have to be a little bit more
telling me what's going on because I
didn't keep up none of that I got like
the bits and pieces the stuff that King
sent me that's like what are we talking
about this I'm like oh okay you're like
this
so shout out to Bone slave up there
um that's Cali family shout out to Big
support that brother supports no matter
what he's probably working right now and
brother I do appreciate everything you
do see you at E3 brother
yeah so let's get let's get straight
into this man what what do you guys want
to talk about first like uh it's because
I heard there's a lot of DC stuff going
on it's not just one thing
good Tyler I'll let you kick it off I
feel like it's won a bunch of stuff
wrapped into one thing with this James
gun decisions seems like everything
pretty much is getting canceled except
for
Suicide Squad and Peacemaker so the two
things he did
a mad bias I'm gonna cancel everything
but what I did that's right anything
before me meant nothing you know so uh
everybody else is pretty much done I
know there's been rumors that uh Jason
Momoa is gonna stay on his Lobo I don't
know if that's a fact or not but that's
definitely been rumored so
I love the balls on him pulse
um
because he comes out and like sweeping
he is he ripped the Band-Aid straight
off took off the stitches took off the
cast I don't give a hell you know you're
gonna feel this pain right now and
you're gonna have time to mourn and get
over it I like his tweet that he put out
he said we have a toxic segment of the
community that thinks that by being a
disrespectful raw and and and and nasty
that you're going to get what you want
that's not gonna work we're not going to
be bullied we're not going to be pushed
we're not going to be uh shoved we're
going to do exactly what we feel is in
the best interest and then there's a
whole statistic about the whole DC
Universe
and what happened during that period of
time in the numbers and the numbers are
abysmal even up to Black Adam so you
have Shazam that's coming up and you
have that flash movie that's coming up
you have Aquaman those are the last
three bastions and Aquaman did pretty
decent but he doesn't care what happens
with this Aquaman
um galgado uh Wonder Woman and uh Jason
Momo was Aquaman
really probably doesn't fit into his
long-term vision of whatever the DC
Universe is supposed to be so
his his thought well we already know
Henry Cavill
doesn't doesn't fit right
um and like I was talking to you guys in
the background and I don't know if you
guys agree with me but let me ask you a
question I know uh attic have you ever
seen Smallville
uh what I watched with Tyler and that's
about all like uh if I didn't watch it
there I didn't watch it ever watch
episodes here and there all right so are
you an avid watcher at Smallville uh
Tyler I have the whole box set okay okay
yeah so so you pretty much know those
are some of the best stories that the WB
had to tell of a young Superman oh yeah
yeah we've never had screen time
with a Superman from the ages of 17 to
33. and I think that's where James Gunn
wants to go I think he wants to go in
that direction in telling some of the
most uh memorable stories that DC has
never told ground Superman in reality
because these are Gods right a Wonder
Woman is a god Aquaman is a God uh he's
a God right so you have to ground these
super superheroes in in a place that the
common man can fill a kinship to and it
can translate into Dollars you know when
when a hero is Out Of Reach and uh it
seems mythical then it becomes comical
becomes far-fetched it becomes uh uh
unidentifiable and the common man won't
go see it you won't get tear jerks you
nobody cared when Superman was laid up
on the table and he couldn't breathe you
know and and um Man of Steel
so we have to grow into that character
and I think that's where James Gunn is
going to go hopefully it works but I
think this toxic Community is trying to
kill a baby before the baby is born and
it's not good I just I don't agree with
it it's as bad as it sounds they're
trying to take the the cancer culture I
root where you know if they're vocal
enough it will get like the higher ups
to Cave but if if the higher ups was
like yo we we trust in Your Vision
clearly we ain't doing or anything right
like like we haven't built a universe
like we're gonna have to
trust that you can do something and if
they just let him come in there and
cancel all of these projects what makes
them think Twitter gonna bully them in
in into canceling him like it's not
going to happen
no I mean that's kind of the problem
DC's always had is I read DC Comics I
don't really read Marvel Comics I saw
that much shame on you
I really like action man but mainly DC
Comics right and DC's always had that
problem of every hero is a God we're
been struck by lightning they're not
grounded where Marvel was like all right
this is a kid who yeah he got bit by a
spider there but he's still a high
school kid and that's why those Marvel
movies were so are so successful that
you can relate to something yeah DC
doesn't have it they can't relate to a
god or
a alien from out of outer space so like
they need to find a way to ground these
characters for them to mean more to you
when you're watching it which you just
don't have right now right you see the
the the dichotomy between DC and Marvel
is this
Captain America was a skinny kid that
was being bullied
and that skinny kid was like I'm going
to go serve my country
right and that's something each and
every last one of us can do go serve our
country but he kept getting denied so
you got to think about those people that
was medically denied every time but they
want to serve with all a heart they want
to do something to pitch in to to give
back right to show that they support
their country and that's what Steve
Rogers represented and he got into
experimental uh program where a drug
turned him into more than what he was
how many people out here has taken a
shortcut to be taken to become more than
what they are there's millions of
athletes that have went down that road
well you know and they said you know the
greatest uh the the road to hell is
paved with the greatest intentions right
and they had to address that in the
Marvel books about Captain America being
essentially a druggie right because
without that super soldier serum in his
body who is he really and they really
addressed it and they went deep into
that character you cannot do that with
Superman
he was born with his powers he came from
another planet he is an alien to this
planet now you can deal with the
isolation of him not really being human
and trying to fit in human form but how
do you do that how do you make that
identifiable to everybody around you you
know so there's little lessons in there
that I believe James done can bring to
these characters because he's worked in
Marvel he's understood the process right
and then I'm pretty sure that he have
steeped himself inside all types of DC
law to get the best history out of him
to bring you know the best iterations of
that character
out of this one thing hold on breaking
news
what Dwayne Johnson just made a tweet
about Black Adam 10 minutes ago what he
said he said my passion of friends I
wanted to give you a long-awaited Black
Adam update regarding the character's
future and the new DC Universe James
Gunn and I contacted and Black Adam will
not be their first chapter of
Storytelling however DC and seven bucks
have agreed to continue exploring the
most valuable ways Black Adams can be
utilized in DC uh in future DC multifice
chapters James and I have known each
other for years and has always rooted
for each others to succeed it's no
different now and I will always root for
DC and Marvel to win in big ways you
guys know me and I'm very thick skinned
and you can always count on me to be
direct with my words oh there's another
one these this is these decisions made
by James and DC leadership represent
their visions of DCU throughout their
creative lens after five years after
five after 15 years of uh Relentless
hard work to to finally make black item
I'm proud of the film we delivered for
the fans worldwide I will always look
back on the fans reaction to blackout
with tremendous gratitude humidity and
love we did great to my very passionate
vocal black item superhero Jennifer I
love you thank you I always listen to
you and do my best to deliver the
entertainment uh we all need and then
have a productive week and happy
holidays to me his his first statement
contradicts his second statement he says
oh you know we're going to you know
utilize Black Adam more in the DC you
know probably through like independent
Universe not the connected universe but
then he says after 15 years of
Relentless hard work to finally make
Black Adam proud of the film like he's
he's acting like it's never like there's
never gonna be a sequel in his second so
that's pretty much guaranteed like Black
Adam is I'd be surprised at this point
if if it comes back in any shape way
shape or form
what do you think Tyler
I mean he's right it does contradict it
a little bit
um I saw a report that somebody said
that they try to get the rock to do a a
cameo and Shazam and he turned it down
yeah I don't know if it's true or not
but that was the report
um I mean he doesn't say he's gonna keep
playing Black Adam he says black Adam's
gonna continue in the DC and then he
starts thanking everybody so I don't
know if it's
ah that character's gonna stay on but I
might not be or
we'll see when they decide to make a
blackout movie if I'm still available
great if not then somebody else will do
it
um but he doesn't give a lot of
information on what exactly what that
first sentence is supposed to mean so
yeah I think he just uh straddled the
fence I think he played both sides I
think uh I mean because his action
speaks louder than words right the fact
that he unfollowed WB the fact that he
unfollowed uh pretty much everybody that
was in the association with
um the project uh
because you know he shares the same
manager as Henry Cavill he politics very
heavily to have Henry Cavill there he
has a a long-term vision for what he
believes is good he wants to be James
and utterly like he yeah DC Universe
yeah the same way he wanted to control
the Fast and the Furious franchise you
know and they had to give him uh what is
that Calvin the Hobbes uh little side
project because he wouldn't sign on to
do certain things unless he didn't he
had a side project so it's always the
Rock's way so pretty much like right now
he he tried to pull a power move and he
ended up getting kicked out like well
Black Adam is always going to be there
you might not be there a Black Adam will
always be there you know you don't own
the character you played the character
and this is where it comes uh into
ownership a lot of things maybe if he
would have played ball a little bit
earlier Black Adam would have turned out
a little bit different but if you have
the comedic tone of Shazam
it doesn't work well with the serious
tone of Black Adam
and Black Adam is a derivative of the
Shazam character remember Shazam came
first
Captain Marvel came first his name is
Captain Marvel in DC Universe
um not to be confused with anything from
Marvel
um and his Logistics with that but the
Shazam character
they found out that uh a lot of his uh
villains weren't really up to Snuff
right so they invented the Black Adam
character a direct competitor to who he
was and he gave him law and history and
stuff like that strength power in order
to uh fight against Shazam and in the
Shazam family it always takes the whole
family to beat Shazam and sometimes
Shazam I mean um Black Adam and Black
Adam sometimes beat some you know back
and forth it's it's very uh nip and Tuck
pulse with that but again
you needed to introduce that character
with Shazam
now maybe James Gunn goes and changes
the tone on Shazam in order to include
Black Adam and maybe you know the rock
reads the script maybe he does come back
maybe he does put on The Heirs that he's
supposed to have the pointy ears that's
what it kind of felt like he was playing
the middle ground because he doesn't
know the future and he doesn't want to
make anyone mad he probably started a
lot of General a lot of friction when he
unfollowed people and then that started
which Amy's like okay you know The Rock
has a huge following we kind of want
them to come but we they don't want like
a Johnny Depp moment where they feel
like people are going to boycott because
people have been kicked off projects so
I I mean okay so I see an eagle hunt say
sorry uh James Gunn's gotta go why
what has James Gunn done right now Nico
talking to you
um that makes you feel that James Gunn
has to go what has he done other than
make
irrelevant characters that none of y'all
cared about and Guardians of the Galaxy
not one of you people would have put
that comic book up and say I want to see
this
it made you care about those characters
and made those characters that Marvel
had because he looked at everything that
they had and said I can make these
characters relevant and he made them
relevant and made them included inside
Infinity war and in Infinity uh Saga he
did Peacekeeper too didn't he Peacemaker
yes
I wasn't feeling the suicide squad as
much but I did I thought Peacekeeper was
a good addition to the DC Universe
Captain America is not a mutant stop
that and the crazy part is
I felt like you never ever would have
thought to put John Cena in that role
but James saw a vision and he made it
work like yeah and that's probably one
of the best HBO Max drinks that I do
look at and here's the problem with the
rock though is he's trying to pull this
Sony thing where he's like I want to do
Black Adam without Shazam yeah he was
supposed to be in the first shazam movie
he refused to do it they want him for a
cameo he refused to do it Shazam is on
his movie at all why did morbius and all
of them not work she don't have
Spider-Man
I want to see morbius if he's not
fighting Spider-Man exactly
and if I was James Gunn I wouldn't walk
rock either what's the point of Black
Adam without Shazam
so
I think they need to work out something
there if he wants to stay on to where
it's like okay but you're the bad guy
you need to be fighting Shazam
so well they show the what was it what I
forgot what number chair that was five
or six number of the chair they showed
the chairs and it was an empty space
sitting there and that's that space was
for Black Adam right and they weren't
going to tell a different story into
getting Black Adam there
and why you know so he he refused uh you
know certain aspects of it and I can
understand that you want your
Independence because you want your movie
to stand on its own but when it becomes
the detriment of the team
that's the problem Wonder Woman it's a
prime example she made an appearance in
Batman versus Superman and had a
phenomenal first out going out the gate
like yes so it's just like you
introduced the character Black Adam
shows up in like Shazam or whatever you
want you you introduce Black Adam he he
gets a lot of hype going into him you
people Vibe with him in someone else's
movie so when you make his own movie
people know who he is because of another
movie and more people are willing to go
yes but instead he's like I want to be
in shazam's video I don't want to be in
in Batman's I want to be in nobody's
people gonna come to me rock let's be
real here people go to the fast and
fierce movies because of the whole panel
the story ludicrous not just you
all right
he lets a lot of that stuff go ahead but
this is why I tell you the rockisms
change what happened I don't want this
to become an indictment against The Rock
right because I really like the Black
Adam film I like it as a standalone
elsewhere movie uh just the same way as
I like Robert Patterson's Batman and and
um Joaquin Phoenix is Joker those movies
can stand alone in their own Universe
the problem with the rock did was and
this is why Henry Cavill is gone and
this is why the people are blaming the
rock for doing this
you
directly made it a Mainline Thing by
adding Henry Cavill so it's not
elsewhere else no more this is the main
line uh uh a main Justice League
Universe now you have to destroy this
universe because he has definitely been
implemented in it already right so you
can't say this is an elsewhere's thing
if this is your main Hero's hair so the
whole Snyder verse had to go and uh
unfortunately the rock is part of that
now
it and I do I do feel like their Vision
with the rock could have worked but the
rock I do feel in the future would have
ended up
throwing a hissy fit because he didn't
get his way in something and it would
have it would have deriled that whole
storyline like it would have been nice
to have like the the uh you know Black
Adam show up and the Black Adam fight
Superman like that would have been cool
that would have been a cool storyline
but I don't know if
Black Adam versus Superman I don't know
I honestly feel like Henry could have
separated that I am part of a film not
the film I don't know if the rock Coulda
did that well I think I think he got too
much too much star uh too much screen
time and I didn't like like I don't I
don't know if he could have played nice
with everyone in the long run he does
good at being an essential person in one
movie but when he gets put into like a
universe he starts to fall apart like he
could never have been Iron Man in that
kind of role because he would have
eventually ended up getting mad because
why is this person getting more screen
time I'm an Iron Man you know what I'm
saying that's why I gotta respect Kevin
if I get in the team for actually
managing all those Eagles and satiating
everybody during the way I'm pretty sure
there was a lot of bumps in the road
stuff that we probably won't hear of
because it was so successful maybe if
they did flop then maybe we wouldn't
hear it but let me get this uh to a lot
of Super Chat from timbercloud I like to
guess clearly he loves this stuff thank
you Tim McLeod thanks man
so where's Nico at Nico Nico I'm talking
to you you really need to explain you
can't leave toxic stuff and not explain
why Nico where is it come on you ain't
got a Super Chat Nico you didn't
superchat before and I read it you see I
don't have all my shades my shades is
here Nico you got the wrong King today
baby
you're not gonna pull that crap see
these Shades is here
glasses is on Nico
I'm Batman Nico let's go let's dance I
actually I'm gonna look into how to do
like audio tune and stuff because I want
to start implementing that in the in
those shows you know who does that
really well guys oh yes yeah I got it I
gotta talk to guys I'm like yo show me
your ways show me your ways info says
you can tame those eagles with cash no
you can't there's certain people here's
the thing when you're talking about
I would say the majority of people that
get cashed for this a lot of them end up
being like the top 10 of of Hollywood
like the top 10 earners once you get to
like where Johnny Depp was where you
have all this money there's that amount
of money that they can give you that's
gonna settle your ego because you feel
like you're good there's nothing they
can do in terms of finances to get you
you have to the only way to serve to
serve those people is to stroke their
ego we're going to give you more screen
time we're going to give you exactly
your own movie like once you have that
kind of the rock type of money
he might not be the richest person in
Hollywood but this man will never
struggle for money he's I'm sure he's
got plenty of Investments you can't
settle him by just putting another zero
in a contract you guys breaking news
breaking news Nico hunt says laugh out
loud I'm not being toxic I'm here
yo Nico I'm just having fun with you I
know you're not toxic don't worry about
it you know what Nico I'm saying you're
toxic though
there's only been two instances in
Marvel that has been reported of egos
getting in the way and it was Edward
Norton with the Hulk and
um oh what's his name there the original
war machine
um oh you're talking about Terrence
Howard yeah both of them supposedly
there he goes he's on the way money and
everything else they're not there
anymore yeah that's Marvel say all right
bye and that's what James is going to be
he's saying I'm making my decisions and
we're gonna live with them they might be
good they might be terrible but we're
gonna find out one way or the other so
that's a huge part that you just said
right there because Terence Howard was
on the precipice of being a war machine
in the very next movie and he felt
because he brought Robert Downey Jr on
and you know because he highly
recommended he he rigged him up he did
that but the contract for Robert Downey
Jr was larger than his so that's where
you know you get egos that come in and
Don Cheadle stood right there took the
pie you know and he and he's still he's
still acting in in Marvel today you know
Don Cheadle really doesn't have to do
anything else but he's allowed to do a
whole bunch of other things and he is uh
you know hotel room Rwanda really opened
my eyes to what range he does have so
the guy is uh absolute genius but then
when we uh get over to uh who was the
the second one that you said that was uh
Edward Norton Edward Norton I loved
Edward Norton what Edward Norton tried
to do was he tried to become the
director the writer and the actor to the
script when you're such a intrusive
individual uh you ostracize yourself
because you become toxic to the whole
project and you can't be talked to you
can't be reason with you can't be
bargained with so you have to go and he
almost got that Incredible Hulk movie
removed from um Canon from the Marvel
Universe I'm happy that they did keep
that Incredible Hulk movie on happy that
they did use the Abomination that they
are going to use the leader because they
did build a good foundation to it but is
the fact that Edward Norton's ability to
be the individual that he is allowed for
uh this guy to come on and and be the
Hulk and I'm so happy that he is because
he's a very humble where he's at he does
the TV you could never get Edward Norton
to do the Disney plus She-Hulk stuff
that would have never happened you know
so
I just I just like exactly where these
guys are and I I think you're right as
far as stroking ego I don't think it's
money that you can throw at these guys
because you know they really don't want
for anything uh everybody especially all
messed up because Henry Cavill was out
of a job no he is and he's doing
Warhammer yeah and to be honest with you
he stated a couple times he wanted out
of that in the first place because he
felt like they wasn't taking The Witcher
in the right direction initially like
yeah I honestly think if he could have
got there's no Realm of the amount of
hate that they got for replacing him
where he couldn't have used that clout
went back and got that job again
but yeah he didn't he didn't even try
because he what he didn't want that I
honestly feel like he loves The Witcher
and he didn't like the way that they
were writing the actual show compared to
The Witcher franchise
no well I didn't I haven't watched The
Witcher so I'll be a fraud
um to tell you I probably watched two
episodes of it and
um
uh I'm not the hugest uh Witcher fan the
video game yes you know I played the
first one and then um I immediately
jumped in the second one the third one I
didn't finish because of the jankiness
on some stuff but they sudden the update
through I just got a backlog I gotta get
into that game but um I did like his
depiction of the character how he looked
in his suit uh how he looked he looked
like Gerald right he looked like he he
fit the part and I saw him fight a
little bit so I'm like I'm gonna give it
a chance I can understand why a couple
of people was upset because they trying
to say this is a direct correlation uh
he quit The Witcher to come back to play
Superman and he got fired and that's not
true
yeah it's just one of those things where
I I do feel like people get a little too
emotional with like
imagination videos and movie franchises
and I mean we do it with games all the
time so I can understand why people do
it movies but it's like at the end of
the day it's like look I'm not saying
James knows what he's doing 100 but I do
think he's got more more pluses and W's
behind his behind his name such as like
Guardian of the Galaxy Peacemaker then
the majority of these people that's
trying to push him out of the position
I got to give a shout out to ksante
what's up brother
um I gotta say though that Edward Norton
was a great Bruce Banner true but I do
like what Mark Ruffalo has done with the
character too
I love
the the human nature that Mark Ruffalo
has brought to the character he he's
brought a certain level of pain that I
think uh playing the Hulk needs uh is
the psycholog see I'm y'all don't see it
in here because there's no Hawk statues
in here in my Red Room there's a crap
ton of Hulk statues
he's probably my greatest character
because he's so misunderstood and
it takes a a hell of an actor shout out
to Bill Bixby I used to love the TV
shows to play that range of Banner
even though the Hulk is the show
Banner is the vehicle that keeps that
show going so you know you have to play
one hell of a banner in order to get
that out of you know the for the
character because it's a duality in that
character it's like moments like in the
original Avengers where they're building
up for him going Hulk again and he's
like I guess it's time and he starts
walking up they're like you never told
us your secret he's like I don't have a
secret I'm always mad
is
it's not just pain but it's a softness
of this Beast that just terrorizes
everything then you have Bruce and he
speaks soft he speaks slow he's real
gentle and it's just a crazy like man I
can't believe this person turns into the
yeah I think that's what makes ruffle
those versions so specials because
there's such a dichotomy such a
difference between him and the Hulk yep
that it's like shocking difference yeah
you can see it right because like when
he was chasing
um this uh what was it black Widow
through the horror character I think
that's the most terrifying that you was
able to see how terrifying is like the
Hulk chasing you right and to go to that
that part where he's after he falls out
of the sky and he's uh putting his
clothes on and he's you know talking to
the the guy the bum gives him the
clothes and he's like yo you know put on
some clothes and to go from that Beast
of an animal
to this uh frail character that is so
humble and so appreciative please thank
you you know type of thing I think his
range is incredible it's absolutely nuts
and they show it from look how scared
Scarlett Johansson was when she's
running away from him to the next
Avengers movie she has a crush on him
yeah like what she's trying to get with
him yeah right which show was like wow
this dude is like not the same as this
Beast exactly he must have said
something sweet to her
all right so we're at the uh the half
hour mark and a little bit more than a
half hour mark and uh I think we should
start getting into the main event
uh this James Cameron
wonderful uh thing uh I'll I'll like uh
Our Guest uh Tyler to uh tell us about
your experience uh where do you what
what kind of movie theater did you see
it at uh what was uh what was your
beverage of choice going in sir so it's
just regular AMC right now Coke you know
it's by myself so I just sat down so you
did you did a couple of lines
um
that's right that's right
[Music]
um
here's my thing right is with the first
Avatar movie
is beautiful
visually stunning yes especially for
back then
especially
I had always kind of thought like the
story I was like I don't really get it I
think it's really overhyped the movie
itself is beautiful but the story I just
it's not for me I don't get it this one
was
completely different I love the story
it's beautiful too right it's like the
first one but the the story is
incredible I thought the second movie
was amazing all the way around I really
enjoyed it
um I wasn't sure if I wanted not just
because my opinion of the first one so I
went and I said okay we'll see what this
is about
and I thought it was I thought it was
excellent all the way around
okay what about you at it
I liked it I didn't feel the choice
I don't even think I drunk anything when
I was there did we get a drink when we
was at that movie Babe
oh yeah we got a Sprite never mind
um all right so you did spray he did
Coke so I I just
I liked it and I felt like it was an
entertaining movie but I did feel like
the last 15 minutes
it was starting to wave down on me it's
like when's this thing ending like you
know what I'm saying like but I'm not
going to say that's like a bad thing I I
do feel like the movie did what it went
out to do it entertained me for the
whole time it's amazing you kept me in
there for two and a half hours and it
took the last 15-20 minutes for me to
start saying that most movies I'm on out
by two
but I I felt like the pacing was good
the story was good I felt like you know
they it's kind of interesting like in
the first one they chose the main
character to be like the chosen one but
in this one they were choosing his
daughter uh which was uh you know we'll
get into the spoiler thing because we're
only gonna uh we're only doing this till
six today because King got some stuff
he's got to do but uh you know we're not
in the spoiling part part of it but so
it's just like I felt like this is a
good movie you know at first I was very
critic I was very what's wrong critical
critical of if it was going to make
money or not because this second night
big area we had like two
two rows of people that's all right so
I'm like you you know I've seen more
people in here watching watching some
some crazy some nonsense but it does
look like the the movie is extremely
profitable almost so I mean they what's
I think they said 600 million they made
in three days that's ridiculous so and
that's good that's the Rock's budget
apparently they got a it was rumored I
don't know if you can uh if you guys
could speak on it it was like 2 billion
before they make profit
I have no idea
well I think what it is is all because
they've already filmed this movie in
next movie like I think that's two
billion is both of those combined yeah
and that would make sense uh you do you
guys I did a little research you guys
know why this movie took so long to come
out
no because they couldn't mocap in the
water five years ago they had to make
the technology for it and it took it
makes sense
it makes sense
um
well okay is it me now yeah it's you all
right so my beverage of choice was uh um
a slushie
and we had nachos all right and we went
to the um the RPO oh I seen it 3D by the
way yes in 3D I didn't want to see it in
3D like we got there late because it's
like a 45 minute drive and I was like is
there one that comes on uh you know in
like 10 15 minutes like the 3D one like
suck because I don't like 3D it gives me
a headache but I was like you know what
I'm gonna watch it 3D and I was thinking
maybe you wouldn't watch it 3D so at
least I could give a perspective of
someone that watched it 3D so I'm
sitting there thinking about content at
the movie theater I need a life man no
well I was thinking about content while
we was going in
um so that's why I took a picture of the
3D glasses as we was going in uh let me
let me say this uh the first movie meant
so much because it was the first movie
that was shot in IMAX and was at an IMAX
theater right
first 3D IMAX experience for myself
and it was that that Moon moving
and um my life is completely different
at that period of time
but uh we got a chance to see it then
and he blew me away the first the first
movie was about air right
and the the possibility of of this world
and flight and stuff and he
depicted all of that the movement the
CGI was top-notch and it's the same way
he did with Terminator you know um the
first Terminator was a revolutionary
movie at that period of time right he
was like wow this is crazy you know the
CGI well the Prosthetics and stuff that
he was using for it and stuff that he
was using for it Terminator 2
was a Master Class
Yale did itself
and I said can he capture that same
magic I don't know why the hell I
doubted James
um um Mr Cameron
going into this film because uh when
from the moment that it started
I knew completely
this is a different film
the the ability to zoom in on the CGI
and moving at 120 frames and sometimes
60 frames and he was switching up camera
uh speeds and lenses
it gave a such a cinematic feel such a
real life feel to the film and the CGI
the HDR the the particle effects
everything that was going on at one time
was mesmerizing and mind-blowing and
then when he got to the other side where
it was water
and remember the first wonderment you
had in the first film where they got
into the forest and was night and then
you saw the glowing lights and it was
just like it was it was a a dance with
your eyes
he did the same thing here with water
and I said this man is an absolute
genius because right now
this is I don't know strike me dead
this is the best CGI I've seen in films
at this moment
and I and I think he's a genius and he
has an eye he has an eye his team has an
I so if attic is saying that he waited
all this time because he couldn't motion
cap in water
the level of dedication for this man to
get his vision to the screen
is second to none and he won't
compromise and it was amazing for me I
saw a video on Tick Tock it was I don't
know if it was him the camera but it
seemed like the director was speaking
and they were he was making questionable
choices about someone like the fighting
scenes and they're like look like this
kind of seems because I guess it was
already three hours I guess internally
they were trying to cut back on the on
how long the film was and they're like
can we please cut this back because like
it it doesn't it doesn't give nothing to
the story nothing a character
development all it does is just this and
he's like but I want to see that so I
think people want to see that like
that's good because you know you want to
director that's that is grounded in what
he feels that the public wants and and I
think he's right because I don't see any
throwaway scenes in the film for myself
maybe I'm still too high on the film I
think the only film that the only scene
that I would think they could have got
rid of and it wouldn't have really
affected the game the story much is is
the [ __ ] part at the end like because I
felt like they could have done that way
shorter and got to the point way quicker
I felt like they were under that ship
for like 30 minutes oh when it was
underwater yeah yeah so he had to build
tension yeah excuses for him right
laughs
so I mean I I agree that I don't think
there's a lot of parts you could take
out I feel like it was
sadly two and a half hours three hours
was condensed compared to probably what
he wanted to do I feel like the movie
flowed well I'm more of a movie person
than him so I didn't think I thought the
movie flew past I was like oh it's over
already all right cool yeah I didn't
even know it was that long to be honest
with you until we got out the movie
theater it was six o'clock in the
evening
yeah so no I mean the
both these movies are beautiful I mean
you're right the best CGI you're going
to see in the movie right now every
scene is just it's incredible and you're
just mesmerized by it and it's uh
I was gonna say it's gonna take moments
like this
to encourage other people to step up
they cgic it's like oh God yes
you because the first avatar
force people to step their game up
so you already know this movie uh
whoever whoever is doing something you
know this is gonna blow them away I mean
so every time I was like
balled up their paper
car Bishop said we're gonna start all
over you know um
so addict do you do you want to start
off some spoilers at this point you want
to start to spoil apart yeah we can
start the spoiler part I think that's uh
Fair uh I'm gonna put the spoiler alert
thing at the back of us what's going on
Christopher Jones General Spartan what's
going on what's going on Killian Brown
all right so hold on people
I did feel like it was good for them
because
I personally feel like
the character I don't know anything
about the Avatar Lord but I personally
feel like once again there's spoiler
alerts on the screen if we spoil
something it's the old fault but anyway
all right remember now this is the part
of the of the joint where if you didn't
see the film
and you don't want it spoiled for you
leave
leave the theater now you see how it's
just me and addict sitting in the
theater
leave I I think that they're gonna
eventually roll with the daughter being
the main character the the daughter of
the character from the first one the one
yeah and I actually felt like
I would have didn't mind that part
wherever it was drowning at the end if
she actually did something relevant all
she really did was like sense some life
pretty much like lighting up bugs to
find where her mom and her and her
sister was and I'm like if you got that
much clout why didn't you find where the
dad was too like I guess he don't matter
like we he could drown it's okay
see see that that doesn't that's your
part right there right that would not
have advanced the story the story was
the mother and the daughter was trapped
and you really thought they were gonna
die and she saved them that was good I I
think it would have been a better
because the whole they were like
building up for her using those powers
like the whole movie like she like
almost every time you saw her she's
doing something she she's playing with
something she's doing something that
wouldn't normally those people can't
that's why they called her a freak every
five minutes so I'm thinking she's
sitting out there she's about to do
something crazy no she just made like
the longest like line you know the lines
that people put in dark rooms to show
where you're going she put like the
longest one of those that you've ever
seen I expected like a bunch of fish or
something to come out there like because
I guess maybe it's because the first one
because she's supposed to be like a
Reincarnation of that Spirit right right
I because in the first one that Spirit
showed up with all the Hostile all the
smoke for the humans at the first one it
showed up with all of the the nature the
the the the the native life they were
just destroying everything so I'm
expecting imma see some like those big
Tusk things those big giant whales are
just gonna show up and like lift the
whole thing or something you know what
I'm saying like I like because the way
they were building it you was gonna see
her use this ability to a degree that
you weren't like that was going to be
like massive you get what I'm saying
I I will disagree with that
because she didn't know
when she was in the other land before
they got to the water
she didn't have a purpose she didn't
feel her purpose right and then she got
to this other land and she still felt
out of place because she missed home
that's the only place that she knew
but
she was the only one that was able to
hold her breath underwater where her
brothers and her sisters struggled
she didn't she didn't struggle
she was actually there effortlessly and
she was playing in the water she was
laying the water with her face looking
at holes in the sand whatever creatures
was down there that's why they was
calling her a freak and her fingers but
the the fact that she bothered no one
quiet laying with her face in the water
tell me how they act like uh she like
they were down in the water for like for
like an hour at the like the the middle
of the movie but at the end it felt like
that like the moment they went
underwater they're sitting there
breathing like they just acting like
they didn't spend half the movie
underwater
and it's different when you're swimming
than when you're trapped under a boat
you know like you have less air and
everything else of course you're gonna
be struggling more man and what's funny
is like she she brings those little
butterfly things that she brings them
she's like mother you only brought one
yeah yeah that's what I'm saying she
brings one and puts it on them and I'm
like you passed like 50 of them if you
knew people was under there why didn't
you grab more like see something
something as little as like that like
she walks by them and she like gently
touches them and they all come with her
you know what I'm saying like it's just
I felt like they were building her up to
do something
spectacular in that movie it never
happened and that never happened like I
just wanted to see like that moment in
the first avatar where things were
looking down and then you just see all
those birds and all those uh creatures
come out of nowhere because that is what
they built up to like when he was
sitting there and he was like well I
wouldn't have wouldn't have been too
much of the same
I yes and no yes it would have been the
same but no it wouldn't be because now
you're actually seeing the embodiment of
this person you know what I'm saying
like and that's that's the biggest thing
I was saying because when he put his
hair or that neural link that's in their
hair in the first one it said look look
at her memories tell me that they ain't
issues tell me that you don't need to
help us what you gotta read that
uh
five dollar Super Chat from Catalan
Brown where did Miles come from uh miles
come from and I don't remember Grace
being pregnant yeah
Grace I don't know
here's what I think happened with the
grace thing at the beginning it's not
you babe it's Grace from the movie okay
so so at the in in the first movie they
try to revive Grace and I think that's
when they gave her the baby because that
I I think instead of Reviving Grace she
put her Essence in grace to be reborn as
a kid right
so
[Laughter]
yo all right so to to to to go to
addicts Park
I thought that uh she would have uh had
those big wheel-like creatures lift the
ship up right
that would have been too easy because we
already did that McGuffin when the the
the kinship will that he had with the
the Sun
saw his friend
being captured by the same people that
killed his mother
and ripped off his fin
and see the problem the reason why I
think we came up and it delivered man
you know what I really liked about it I
liked where it showed sometimes when
you're being bullied you got to pop
someone in the mouth like that's why
that's why he was ostracized from this
from the group because the group took a
stance
this whole species took a stance of
non-violence
we're going to take it we're going to
keep taking it and those beasts could
easily destroy
um the humans easily but they would just
you know continue to take this beaten
and he was just he wasn't one to do it
he was one to Buck up against the system
and he saw his friend he did all that by
himself yes could you imagine if it was
five of them and he didn't die
he didn't even remotely get hurt like he
was so intelligent I loved the botanist
who uh was saying that how intelligent
they were because you could see in the
cerebral cortex uh how uh the brain is
so much larger and the the part where
creativity and music and everything
forms is so much more advanced than
humans and they're going there and
they're taking that sap out
which you know gave you a whole thought
process of wailing and stuff like that
and you can see where uh James Cameron's
uh passions lie right and what
underlying tones that he's trying to
tell the public in in in changing uh how
we do things uh you know stop taking uh
from indigenous population uh stop
invading this you know stop mining
resources stop killing this and stop
doing that
um Revenge leads to emptiness you know
type of feeling
I I thought
the the whole movie as a whole was done
well when they started breaking down
the the circles of trust right whereas
you have the the marine guy who got
killed he has to realize that he's dead
now if he's seeing this he comes back as
an avatar they did a really good job
with human emotions they did a really
good job because they showed where you
know that dude saw his kid he ends up
turning uh pretty much turning against
the humans they show that even though
that he went through all of this at the
beginning of that throughout the whole
movie he still saved him in the end
because he knew that was his father or
you know of remnants of it I I really
liked how they did that and they showed
him too though yeah and they they
because they and I liked what they did
with the humans that was on the ship
when they were draining it like that
dude was probably going and drinking
some alcohol when he left there he was
sitting there he told him how the
process works and then when they see him
die he's like it just walks away it's
just like you could tell that he's there
because he has to be there not because
he wants to be there because he wants to
be there because he has he acted he
actually
[Laughter]
um
when the sun died what was you gonna say
Tyler no no no go ahead go ahead because
that this is going to go into what I was
doing so what you was going to say right
yeah yeah when the sun died
and to see a mother's anguish
you know growing up in the Bronx in in
in in in New York
I've seen that I've seen that pain on a
mother
I've seen that that that that that pain
you know you attend a lot of funerals uh
growing up in the condensed uh un
unhealthy conditions
in in some places
to see Zoe to pick that rage
that moment that moment she had to be
very present very present at that moment
and her rage is right there and she's
screaming and she's bubbling over she
wants to collapse she wants to break she
wants to fold she wants to you know just
pack it all in because you know he
brought us to this land and they're
still following us anyway we could have
defended where we were and my son is
dead the whole thing you could tell that
whole time when he's like let's go to
battle and she's like fine and we could
tell that whole time she'd be like we
could kill somebody humans it's about
time but when he told her
I need you strong
I need you to harness this this this
rage this passion that you have right
now in your chest I need you here I
can't do this without you because he
knows if she goes wrong we're we're
screwed you know
and that moment between because it was a
lot of connection moments in this film
but that moment between a husband and a
wife if anybody was really watching the
the the household structure
yeah the woman has to say the man the
first and they've done this in all of it
when when he went to go see the other
Chieftain and they the the wife was
really refusing and he looked over like
this dude helped us be
and he was like please don't make me be
that guy to this dude
and she was like okay I'm gonna let you
be the man
and the same thing with Zoe's character
where the the husband had to give up his
Matrix of leadership to to go to another
foreign land for them to do it over
again to start over to Humble themselves
to be asked into some place and she
followed her husband to this place so at
this moment now where her son is dead
and that was a real emotional moment and
he's like I need you really present
right here with me and it was that was
the oil for the movie she was like she
was like a demon after when she just got
on that you could tell that like it's
like equivalent like there's this
there's this uh show called like the
originals and Vampire Diaries and like
it's pretty much like a vampires
werewolves and stuff and the vampires
could do something where they turn off
their Humanity where like they're no
longer filling emotions anymore and
that's what I felt like when she stood
up like she just split that switch and
she's like I'm about to go rage off on
these people
she kept like two people in like five
seconds like I gotta read this super
chat I gotta read this Super Chat
Christopher Jones with the 4.49 uh sends
uh you know I'm gonna round you up to
five dollars uh five pound Super Chat uh
Christopher Jones I do appreciate
everything uh the token took 500 bullets
to the gut and said nah son your DPS
game is weak
I swear back off the boat like Hector
the Macho Man you know what I liked when
he took that when when the well took
that that was doing so much damage with
that wire it was Unreal like you think
it's over he he threw it on the thing he
said okay he's gone he's looking for he
jumps back over and he still has the
wire and just killed everyone again like
oh
all right we gotta we gotta start
closing off guys uh
Brown Daniel would get God of War
flashbacks when his son kept getting on
uh in trouble
uh I I feel like they were trying to
show like and to be honest with you
that was kind of done that was probably
one of the biggest critiques I can give
it I felt like they could have done you
know the the interaction between them
and to see people a little bit better
um it just it felt a little forced just
a little bit like not like mad like I
just understand where you have that much
hatred towards them and you just like oh
let's go out fish about past the past
the uh uh the barrier let's go do that
after they just like you and them just
fought so now you just believe in them
like five seconds later see attic this
is where I'm gonna have to Buck up
against that
I've been that cousin [ __ ] up on me
I've been that cousin that's gone down
south
in in Fort my cousins
right and right after that we go over to
get ice cream and the same thing so
those Caribbean cousins that Caribbean
that was a whole Caribbean thing if if
you want to say it was West Indians or
Dominicans or whatever it was funny it
was cute
um but again I understand it because
their kids they want to fit and they
want to belong but they got to learn a
place and they gotta learn the hierarchy
in it and yeah to fight but to also get
little Revenge
yeah they do that I mean you know it's
it's it's it's it's the rite of passage
with children in order to bond you know
so I fought my cousins and you know went
to the bowling alley after that and you
know stuff like that and wind up getting
in trouble because they set me up let's
go let's go and do these popcorn so we
can get you up out of here okay Tyler
what how many popcorns would you give
this movie
oh we have a rating system of one to
five five meaning
oh my God and you know there you know
one meeting so so for me I'd say it's
probably a four
um like I said I went into kind of lower
expectations because first one was uh
whatever uh but I enjoyed it a lot so
I'd say four popcorns
what about you King I give it four
popcorns as well I gotta Reserve that
five popcorn thing for something that
has
encapsulated me into uh a nut case so I
got this Reserve five but it's a four
and trust me when I say four popcorns is
what it is it's dope
I had to give it a four two uh I felt
like it was a well-paced movie and I
wanted you guys to realize how hard it
is to make a well-paced three and ah
three hour plus movie it's it's almost
impossible and they did a very good job
they kept me entertained like I said it
was just like the last 15 minutes and I
think that was mainly because I'm like
man I'm hungry I need to use the
bathroom I don't think that was a movie
I was like this place needs to end so I
could go do stuff like
but you know I think it was a good movie
man I think you guys should definitely
go watch it uh you know hopefully you've
watched it if you're on the spoiler part
by now I think you guys would enjoy it
when it comes out on that uh DVD you
know I'm sure it's gonna look
spectacular on Blu-ray
yep
I'm I'm gonna probably pick up my last
uh 4K Blu-ray DVD which will probably be
that um I'm so excited to hear that they
do have sequels you know in the making
and I want to see what those avatars
look like on other sides of the planet
um because you have water you have air
so it's probably like uh uh it's funny
Avatar right Last Airbender
um and you're looking at air water fire
you know and and stone ground I think so
I think the Earth would have been where
they were I think Earth would have been
where they were originally from yeah in
the forest I I don't think so I think
they were here because remember they
were flying
and they were in the tree so yeah that
would be air probably that's air yeah so
ground got to be dusty and dirty and
these dudes got to have like some weird
kind of skills because some other dudes
had this big ass uh fins on their arms
some Tremors from the Tremor movies
they riding some weird stuff that rides
on the ground imagine if they have like
armor that lets them go underground with
these things too
oh yeah riding probably giant rhinos
that could dive in the ground that's
crazy
um appreciate it for coming through here
uh you know you guys definitely uh all
right King real quick we're about to
leave uh what What's that show on
Netflix I gotta watch again what's that
called Baki Baki spell that
b-a-k-i
okay I will fit I will finish 10
episodes you finish season one of of
Attack on Titan before the end oh yeah
yeah I've watched I watch more I watch
more attack of Titan yeah and we will
have a breakdown of Attack on Titan
season one when we come back but I
appreciate for coming through we're
gonna go ahead and close out of here
peace King peace happy happy how